as we get going let's think I know
you've got this almost 99% chance you've
got this in front of you but I still
want to remember what this is all about
and what we're trying to think through
here what we're trying to arrange in our
heads okay last week we started this
idea of geometrical applications of
differential calculus it's a bit of a
tongue twister and we were interested in
particular objects specifically
particular points on curves and what
calculus could tell us about those
points so here's where we were begin and
I said there's these three overlapping
circles and we focused on this circle in
the middle
do you remember what kinds of objects
all of these objects what are they
called starts with an S
we call these stationary points right
stationary points so you've already got
this on your page so you don't need to
rewrite this unless you do need to
rewrite this now something you may want
to add on and I'm hesitant to put this
on I don't want to make this too busy
maybe your diagram is already quite full
if you have another color though good
morning one of the things that makes a
stationary point a stationary point sort
of an alternative definition if you like
is that if you draw a tangent to a curve
at a stationary point without exception
if you're stationary points really
stationary then your tangent is always
going to be a horizontal line like that
in fact on every single one of your
stationary points you should be able to
draw or even just put your ruler against
your graph and you should see oh yes
horizontal line is tangent which by the
way answers a question Eric I think you
posed last week which was okay we looked
at these um overlapping circles what was
this one know start with this one oh is
this one over here what was that called
we called these turning points because
as you can see on either side of the
stationary point you're either going
down and then up are you going up and
they're down so these points aren't
turning around it's 90 points
you've got these guys over here and then
you have these weird which I haven't
explained yet these points of inflection
over here but what about are there any
such things as as a bad end as
stationary points that are neither of
these stationary points that do not turn
and stationary points that do not I'll
explain this in a second do you not flex
whatever that means
is there such a thing as something
in-between did anyone come up with an
example and I gave you being clue by the
way I just introduced reintroduce to
these are these objects do you want to
think where could a graph be stationary
but neither turnaround nor do this weird
flex Eve business yeah a straight line
which is why I drew all these tangents
here right by definition if another way
of describing a stationary point is a
place on the curve where a horizontal
line is tangent right well if you have a
horizontal line then everywhere on that
graph a horizontal line will be tangent
does that make sense it just touches
intersects and it shares the same
gradient that's that's what at agent is
okay it is a bit of a arm a trivial
example which is why we don't put it on
there but there you go for completeness
sake if you want to label the non-bang
you know for example I just put example
graphs on here example equations so I
think I said plus minus x squared over
there plus minus X cubed those are both
very easy examples to think of not the
early ones by any stretch of the
imagination but easy examples to think
of I don't know like y equals 0
that'd - that'd be an example of a
horizontal wipe Y comes any constant
really ok now algebraically what's going
on what binds all these things together
is this geometric definition but in
addition to that how did we find like I
taught you how to do two things with
these stationary weights right I told
you how to find them and also determine
which which of these is it what do we
call that determine their nature very
good it which means are you are you this
are you that are you one of these so
what what binds all that together how
you find a stationary point is you
for something you to do with the
derivative do you member what you're
looking for you want the derivative do
you want a DX you want it to be equal to
zero if the derivative is zero you are
guaranteed a finding a stationary point
that's really important what you'll find
as we go through this topic is that some
of your tests are not guaranteed tests
right you'll find something you're like
oh maybe that means I'll find this
object but maybe you won't we one of the
reasons we start here is it's nice and
simple you find that you guaranteed a
stationary point okay but all we want to
do is tease apart a little bit if you
want to make a heading
what's your textbook cause this next
section is critical values I'm not a
huge fan of this name because what I
find is it gets used in different ways
in different contexts if you go to the
other side of the world critical values
may be may be used so that phrase may be
used to refer to something else but what
they're talking about is when does
something interesting happen not just
including this including this but other
things so I'm going to put an example
over here in a second which doesn't fit
this so it's not a stationary point but
it definitely turns it's a graph that
you're actually quite familiar with it's
a graph that starts like this it's going
down and then it changes direction it
goes up but it doesn't do this we learnt
about it in terms one it was really
unusual because it's not curved even
though it turns around can you want L me
what this graph is what's this graph
this is the absolute value of x right at
least that's what I've tried to make it
look like so what is this well does it
turn I have placed it in this circle
because it turns it's going down then
it's going on okay but do you see why
it's not in this circle over here right
I've described this in a bunch of
different ways is the tangent horizontal
at our I should mark it in and our
important point here a critical point if
you like and the answer is no you can't
say it's the taejun
because if you drew it across it doesn't
just touch it actually kind of collides
with it right why is this well here's
the key what it kind of function is is
this it's a piecemeal function that idea
of a piecemeal function we call this one
theme the absolute value of X but that's
actually mathematical shorthand for two
different objects we're gonna need some
space underneath this or on a new page
or something like that I want us to
investigate this object and work out
what on earth is going on why it's over
here and not over there okay so if I say
Y is the absolute value of x that is
like I said shorthand for two things
what are the two things that make up the
absolute value of X okay so the first
thing or the second thing is that the
absolute value of X is equal to just X
if X is a positive number or if it's
zero actually doesn't matter where we
put zero because it doesn't have a sign
okay so the absolute value of 5 is just
5 okay but the absolute value of X is
also something else it's jekyll-and-hyde
right sometimes it's not X sometimes it
is yeah you slap a minus sign on the
front right when is that if X is less
than 0 so I have this domain restriction
that tells me the absolute value of X
performs in these different ways okay
and therefore when you think about this
if I were to differentiate well if you
have the function which is two things
then it stands to reason that the
gradient function is also two things
yeah so I'm going to get two different
parts here what's the derivative of
minus X it's just minus one this is
about as easy function as you can get so
if X is less than zero then you get this
as the derivative okay what if the
absolute value of X is greater than with
X is greater than or equal to zero so
it's just one if now just watch out for
this this is a bit weird okay see how
I've got an an equality up here right
I've got the boundary there and actually
as we point out if I put the boundary up
here rather than here it actually
doesn't change the result you get
exactly the same
Graff yes but over here I can't do that
I can't do that the boundaries not
included let's think about why we know
what this absolute value function looks
like as a piece people think we're
familiar with this okay but what on
earth does this look like what does this
graph look like draw a small set of axes
underneath here for me oh wait am i red
go here just a small set of axes because
this turns out to be a very very simple
graph what we going to graph here is a
is this function here the gradient
function you've seen in your exercise
often they will give you a graph and
they'll say hey what is the derivative
look like you draw that or they'll ask
you vice versa they'll say here's a
picture of what the derivative looks
like they don't tell you what the
algebra but they say here's a picture
something like the original graph where
the derivative came from okay so let's
think about this part what does that y
equals that equals negative 1 what does
that look like on the graph well which
side of the graph am I looking at think
about the domain which side I'm with the
left hand side because X is negative
right so negative 1 is just a um it's
just a horizontal line like that it
stops there so what do I put on the end
I put a hollow circle because it's not
included that actual value is not there
ok on the other side when I go positive
well if you have a look at this part the
gradient is also constant but it's up
here it's a positive one I shouldn't put
a value there should Knight okay there's
negative one and here is positive one
now why do I include that value there
look it exists at x equals zero and I
don't include the value here well do you
remember about limits right the whole
idea with limits is if you want to say
something is continuous then when you
come from one side and you come from the
other you should arrive at the same
point right so see this guy see this guy
here if you approach zero from this side
you come down to y equals zero if you
approach zero from this side you also
come to the same point right but here as
you converge on x equals zero they are
not coming to any agreement
any client if you want to borrow a
seriousness sequence language right
they're not they're not convergent
they're not going towards the limit
doesn't have any meaning right so one of
these values is no better than the other
right it's like which one is the more
valid value of the answer is neither of
them okay so if you recall we talked
about this language of I don't have a
good example here but we talked about
this language of continuity do you
remember what that means right you can
draw your graph just like I did this one
without picking out your pen which also
means as you approach from one side as
you approach through you that you're
approaching the same value okay now when
your derivative is not continuous
because look there's a break you see how
there's a hole in it right x equals zero
the derivative is not anything okay we
say at that spot it is not not
differentiable because when you
differentiate you don't get a sensible
value okay so let me say this again what
is continuity mean continuity means your
graph has no holes in it right can you
draw the whole thing in one hip okay
differentiability means we want your
derivative to be continuous this
derivative has holes in it so it's not
continuous that means the original
function isn't differentiable at that
point okay so it turns of but it's not
stationary okay